We have to do it about energy prices Sim
it has to be about energy prices
We were gonna do a video about something
else today but we have to do it on energy prices
because massive things are happening that
are going to affect you and your family
and you need to understand what's going on
in the last couple of months you'll probably be
aware there have been significant increases in
energy and food prices in the last couple of weeks
with the escalating crisis in Ukraine there's been
significant further increases in those prices
i woke up this morning and i saw the oil price
had hit $140 a barrel for the first time in more
than 10 years the wheat price has increased 45%
just this week and 65% this month you are not
seeing these prices in your bills or the shops
yet but you are going to, what that means is on
top of the already significant increases in the
cost of basic living - bills & food prices
are going to increase significantly more
this is going to cost an ordinary family
like yours thousands of pounds a year
in many cases this will be thousands of
pounds a year that that family doesn't have
that means a large number of families in this
country will not be able to heat their homes to
feed their kids to pay their mortgages to pay
their rent people are going to become homeless
millions of people are going to be
in these kinds of situations here
we have to do something about it, the media
and economists are presenting this like
it's an unavoidable consequence of what's
happening in Ukraine like nothing can be done
here are some facts you need to know
the averagebillionaire in this country increased
their wealth by £630million during Covid
the first year of Covid saw the biggest ever
increase in billionaire and millionaire wealth
ever in the history of this country
billionaire & millionaire wealth increased by 22%
in just 1 year, ok, this is not a situation where
everybody's suffering this is a situation where
you and your family are suffering but billionaires
and millionaires have never ever made more money
in the history of this country okay so when people
tell you there's nothing that can be done to
help your family pay the bills and heat your home
i want you to realize make sure you're
aware and the people you know are aware
there has never been more money in the bank
accounts of the rich and the super rich
this is not a force of nature
this is a political choice
okay now for the economics bit, who uses the
most energy? rich people have got bigger houses
bigger cars and take more flights, in the extreme
cases, they've got luxury yachts and private jets
they use the most energy, so when energy prices
go up, it should hurt them the most right? wrong!
rich people might use 10 times as much energy as
you but they'll have 100 times as much income and
500 times as much wealth so as a fraction of their
income and their wealth the amount they spend on
energy and food is basically nothing if we look
at disposable income the situation is even more
extreme right disposable income is your income
after you take away rent, food, mortgage, bills
a lot of ordinary families have nothing left
that means they have nothing with which to pay
this extra two-three thousand pounds a year listen
the rich are generally sitting on half a millionpound
a million pound disposable income if their
bills go up ten thousand pound it's not going to
hurt them at all whereas for ordinary families
they're going to be left with nothing to eat
when you hear energy prices going up i want you to
understand this is a tax on the poorest insociety
poor and ordinary families are going topay where
as rich families are not even going tonotice
this way of dealing with the crisis
hurtsordinary families the worst
so how should we deal with this?
so how should wedeal with this?
we need to use less energy most
families are using just about as much energy as
they need to heat their homes and get themselves
to work and back whereas the super rich are often
using way more energy than they need the
sensibleway to deal with this crisis would be
to ask the rich and the super rich to reduce their
energy consumption but when prices go upthat
doesn't affect the rich's behaviour at all they can
easily afford that it will be ordinary families
forced to reduce their energy
consumptionby not heating their home
now economists have beensaying for a long time
that the best way to reduceenergy consumption
is to put a tax on energy use,the problem with this
is, as we're seeing inthis crisis poor and ordinary
people spenda much higher % of their income &
disposable income on energy than richer people
so if you tax energy use it pushes the price
of energy up like we're seeing now and that
massively hurts poor and ordinary families
and does nothing for the rich and super rich
so is there a better solution how about instead
of taxing people for using energy such that poorer
people lose a big chunk of their disposable income
we start rewarding people who use less than the
average amount of energy that would mean that the
majority of families who use less than the average
would start receiving money every year for the
energy that they save this way the rich who use
the most energy would be paying money to poor
and ordinary people instead of punishing poor
and ordinary people for something they did nothing
to cause we can actually reward poor and ordinary
people for using less energy, look this
isn't just an idea that I made up, this is an
idea called the carbon dividend and it's been
around for a long time it's a very simple way
of reducing energy consumption in such a way that
instead of punishing the poor you transfer wealth
from the rich and the super rich who can afford
to pay it towards the poor and ordinary people
who are often struggling just to survive it's
very simple you can reduce energy consumption
on the back of the rich but we're choosing to do
it on the back of the poor why are we doing that?
you know i'm not sure to be honest i'm not
sure why we're not doing that and maybe
Rishi Sunak who is worth an estimated 200
million pounds and whose father-in-law is
a billionaire or one of his people can get in
touch with me and explain why we're choosing
to load this crisis on the back of ordinary people
instead of taxing millionaires and billionaires
but in the meantime i'm going to have to assume
that Rishi Sunak and the current government
do not have your best interests at heart
so what is the government actually doing?
they're gonna have to do something and they're
gonna throw a few schemes together to give a few
families a couple of hundred pounds, bear in mind
you are losing thousands of pounds during this
crisis and the super rich are making millions, are
they raising taxes on the super rich? well actually
they're raising national insurance which
is a tax which specifically hits your wages
and specifically excludes the incomes
of millionaires and billionaires
listen what's happening here is serious it's
not funny it's going to hurt millions of poor
and ordinary families yeah ordinary people
like you are going to suffer in this crisis
while the rich and the super rich are
making millions even billions of pounds
it doesn't have to be that way the money
is there we can support ordinary people
but only if we choose to tax the rich and the
super rich but they're not going to give it to
us easy we're only going to get that
if wecome together and push back
keep watching
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives, some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy - that is not true!